تونس وما يجري فيها كانت ضمن ملفات سالت
عنها قبل الحصاد الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو الذي وجهت اليه اولا
سؤالا عن الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله
سيد انطونيو العام للامم المتحده اهلا
وسهلا بكم
في الماضي اوتريت مقابلات في غرف صغيره
الان الاستوديو يعني تقدما رائعا اهنئكم
عليها اهلا وسهلا شكرا لك لو بدانا بالوضع
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بلده حواره
تخضع للحصار لليوم السادس على التوالي هذا
الوضع وممارسات المستوطنين هناك تعرضت
للتنديد من عديد الدول من الولايات
المتحده من الامم المتحده ايضا
وسؤالي هو كيف تتابعون هذه الاوضاع في
الاراضي المحتله
انا اتابع ذلك ببالغي القلق انا اؤمن
ايمان صادقا بحل الدولتين واعتقد انه لا
توجد خطه بديله عن حل الدولتين اتذكروا في
الماضي عندما كنت رئيسا للوزراء في
البرتغال كان هناك في مكتبه اللقاء مع
شيمون تيريس ويصل عرفات لعده سنوات
وبذلنا الجهود من اجل ان ينعقد السلام بين
فلسطين واسرائيل بلدين والقدس الدروس لم
تكونوا عاصمه
في التعايش في امن وامان للاسف نحن نعود
الى الوراء في هذا المشروع ومن الضروره
بمكان تجنب اي اجراءات احاديه المستوطنات
مخالف للقانون الدولي وهي تقوض حل
الدولتين ايضا عمليات الطرب والان الحالات
الحالات الاعتداء التي الان بالعمليات
التي تسبب الكثيره من الالم نحن ضد اي عمل
ارهابي نحن ضد التحريض على العنص نحن نؤيد
حق الدوله اسرائيل في ان تعيشها بامن لكن
الامر نفسه يجب ان ينطبق على الشعب
الفلسطيني والشعب الفلسطيني الان يعانون
بطريقه مريحه هذا يقودنا الى سؤال قديم
جديد ومتجدد الى متى ستستمر اسرائيل كدوله
فوق القانون الدولي فوق القانون الدولي
ومحبيه فوق ذلك
لا يمكن ولا ينبغي ان يكون كذلك القانون
الدولي ينطبق على جميع لا توجد دول اكثر
مساواه من الاخرى من الضروره تماما ان يتم
احترام القانون الدولي من قبل الجميع
والامم المتحده واضحه بهذا الصدد الصدد
للاسف ما نراه حتى الان هو ان الكثير من
قرارات الامم المتحده لم تطبق والنظام
الدولي يفتقر الى الادوات التي يتم فيها
تطبيق القانون هذه واحده من المشكله التي
يعاني منها نظام الحوكمه الدولي وهذا يعني
من المبرر ان تكون هناك اصلاحات لتجعل
قانون الاكثر فاعليه سيدنا الامين العام
اكيد انكم سمعتم لكثير من
الاراء المتداوله في العالم العربي وهي
التي تشير الى يوصف هنا في المنطقه
بالنفاق الدولي في تعامل الامم المتحده
والمجت مع الدولي بين الوضع في اوكرانيا
والوضع في فلسطين هذا يتم تداوله باستمرار
حتى ان سفير موزمبيق وهو رئيس دوله مارس
في مجلس الامن الدولي عندما سئل هذا
السؤال تهرب منه هل يحرجك هذه هل تحرجكم
هذه المقارنه
امين عام انا ليس لدي النفاق او ازدواجيه
مع معايير لا انا ولا الامانه العامه لكن
اذا ما القينا نظره صادقه الى ما يقوم به
مجلس الامن الدولي والمجتمع الدولي في
كثير من تدخلاته ونشاطاته صحيح هناك
ازدواجيه معايير ليس فقط فيما يتعلق
باوكرانيا وفلسطين لكن هناك ايضا اوضح
اخرى تخص البلدان الناميه بشكل عام تواجه
نظاما دوليا ونظام الاقتصاديا ماليا دوليا
لا يتفق مع مصالحهم هنا لدينا ازدواجيه
معايير ايضا قدره المؤسسات الماليه
الدوليه للدعم
البلدان المتقدمه هي اكثر من قدرته على
دعم الدول النائمه نحن لا نعيش في عالم
نسوده العدل نعيش في عالم كثير من جوانب
الحاكم الدوليه تحتاج الى الاصلاح اصلاح
النظام اصلاح النظام التجاري اصلاح منظومه
الامم المتحده هناك الكثير من المجالات
تحتاج الى نظام الاكثر عضلا وهذا وهي من
الامور التي ادافع عنها بشكل مستمر انا من
واجبك امين عام ان افعل ما استطيع من خلال
القدرات المتاحه لديه والتي ترتبط كثيرا
لكي تجعلني صوت الذين لا صوت لهم لكن هناك
امر واضح وهو اننا لا نمتلك نظام حوكمه
عالميه يستطيعوا التعامل مع المشكلات
الكبيره التي نواجهها المشكلات مثل مشكلات
فلسطين ليس فقط بل حتى المشكلات العالميه
مثل الاحتباس الحراري تغيرات المناخيه
وايضا مع الامكانيات الكبيره والفوائد
الكبيره ما تزال هناك حقوق انسان مثلا
تتعرض للتقوير على نطاق واسع سيد قطيرش
البعض لاحظ في الكلمه التي
يتموها في مجلس الامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان انه عندما بداتم في سرد
الانتهاكات في عديد اماكن العالم اشرتم
الى الصين اشرتم الى ميانمار اشرتم الى
دول اخرى ولم تشير الى الممارسات
الاسرائيليه او الى فلسطين البعض لامكم
على ذلك وسال حتى السيد ستيفاندو جريك
فقال هذا ليس مقصودا اريد ان اسمع ردك انت
كلا كلا المساله بسيطه انا كنت اتحدث عن
التقارير التي
يقدمها مفوض حقوق الانسان استنادا الى
قدراته وليس
للتفويض الذي بالنسبه
لفلسطين هو مفوض بذلك وهناك تقارير من عده
جهات تتعامل مع ذلك انا اذا ما كنت اتحدث
فقط هذا كان السياق مداخله المقاطعه التي
من خلال رؤيه بناء على مبادره من مفوضيه
حقوق الانسان لم تتضمن فلسطين لان
التقارير على حول فلسطين تقارير الزاميه
السؤال الاخير فيما يتعلق بالموضوع
الفلسطيني فيه كلماتكم امام مجلس الامن
الدولي في الذكرى الاولى
للغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا او حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اشرتم الى اوضاع الاوكرانيين
فقلتم
حياتهم جحيم حقيقي تتحدث عن الاوكرانيين
لو طلبت منكم ان تصفوا
حياه الفلسطينيين ماذا تقولون
بكثير من الظروف هم ايضا يعيشون وضعا
جحيميا وان تعيش في غزه حيث لديك عدد كبير
من الناس في مساحه ضيقه تحت حصار
مع نشاط مع تهديدات ارهابيه من متعدده
الانواع
الحياه في غزه في الحقيقه في كثير من
جوانبها
حياه جحيم اذا ليس لدي ازدواجيه معايير
هنا للاسف هناك اوضاع كثيره في العالم
يعيش فيها الناس في ظروف
دراماتيكيه وينبغي ان لا نحبط طرفا ضد اخر
انا على وجه الخصوص على وجه الخصوص معني
بوضع الشعب الفلسطيني
ولا احاول ان اغير من لهجه كلامي عندما
اتحدث عن وصفي مشكلاتهم انا واؤكد مره
اخرى اعتقد ان من الاهميه لمكان ان نجد
حلا حلا يستند الى حل الدولتين وان تكون
دروسا لم القدس كعاصمه لكلا البلدين تعيش
في امنه بامان اسرائيل تحتاج الى الامر
الفلسطيني نحتاجون الى الامن ايضا لو سمحت
انتقل الى ما يجري في تونس ما يجري في
تونس جعل هذا البلد من بلد ملهم في عمليه
الانتقال الديمقراطي لمده 10 سنوات الى
بلد
ينتكس وبسرعه كيف تنظرون الى ما يحدث في
تونس خاصه مع موجه الاعتقالات ومع ما
يتعرض له المهاجرون الافارقه هناك من من
ممارسات بعد خطاب للرئيس قيس سعيد
ذلك بحق انا عايشت هذه الاحداث احداث
الربيع العربي للاسف في عده بلدان تحول
الربيع الى الشتاء طبعا الربيع العربي بدا
في تونس والديمقراطيه في تونس انا اعتز
بها وانظر بكثير من القلق الى تطور
الاوضاع لكن على وجه الخصوص من المهم ان
نقول ان المهاجرين يجب ان يحضروا الحمايه
اينما كانوا مهاجرون حقوق الانسان وهذا
ينطبق على تونس كما ينطبق على اوروبا
واماكن اخرى في العالم وعندما اسمع ان
القاده السياسي يصفون المهاجرين بطريقه لا
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار احترامك كرامتهم
وحقيقه انهم بشر لهم حقوق حقوق انسان هذا
امر يشعرنا بالصدمه العميقه يشعرني
بالصدمه العميقه في تونس وفي اوروبا وفي
كل مكان وبال نسبه لاوضاع حقوق الانسان هل
لديكم قلق خاص مما يجري من اعتقالات هناك
اعتقد ان واحده من الامور المهمه هو ان لا
ينبغي ان يسجن احد بسبب ارائه السياسيه
لا تبرر اعتقال اي شخص الناس يجب ان
يعتقلوا عندما يرتكبون الجريمه عندما
يهددون يكونون تهديدا للمجتمع وليس عندما
يعبرون عن وجهات نظرهم حتى لو كانت وجهات
النظر هذه مخالفه مع الحكومه او ايا كان
اي مؤسسه اخرى اعمل من ان الحوار سيسود
وامر من سيكون ممكنا لتونس في المستقبل ان
تكون ذلك البلد المنفتح الديمقراطي الذي
كلنا سعدنا
بتهنئتهم عندما كانت ايام الربيع العربي
وظروفه قائمه الكل يتحدث عن ضروره عدم
تاسيس
المساعدات التي تقدم في موضوع الزلزال
ولكن ما رايكم في من اعتبر هذه المساعدات
نوعا من الفرصه
للتطبيع مع الرئيس بشار الاسد وهو الذي
يخضع هو ونظامه لعقوبات دوليه طويله
نحن لا
المساعدات باي شكل من الاشكال الى حد ما
نحن ضحايا ذلك التسيس لكن علي ان اقول هنا
ان العقوبات لا يمكن ان تقوض الاستجابه
للزلزال انا طلبت في حاله جائحه كوفيد
وهذا ينطبق على سوريا كما ينطبق على اي
وضع اخر في العالم عندما ظهرت الجائحه
طالبت بتعليق العقوبات فيما يتعلق بشروط
الجائحه عندما حضر وقع الزلزال ايضا طلبته
تعليق العقوبات التي قد تؤخر الاستجابه
علينا ان نفصل تماما بين السياسه وما هي
من بين حاجات الناس الذين هم في حاله
معاناه الذين ينبغي ان نفعل كلما نستطيع
لانقاذهم بشكل مستقل عن من هو
مسيطر ويحكم المنطقه التي هم يعيشون فيها
شكرا جزيلا سيدي الامين العام للامم
المتحده السيد انطونيش على هذا اللقاء
شكرا لكم
السعاده البالغه نعود معكم واتمنى لكم كل
النجاح في عملكم واود ان اؤكد مره اخرى
مدى اهميه الامم المتحده اهميه حريه
الصحافه نرى الكثير من الصحافيين يتعرضوا
قتل في العام الماضي 50% اكثر من العام
الذي قبل انتم ايضا مررتم بحادثه شيرين
التي قتلت واود ان اعبر عن التزامي العميق
بحريه الصحافه وتضامن مع كل الصحافيين في
كل انحاء العالم الذين يضحون بحياتهم لكي
نحصل نحن على المعلومات الصحيحه